are you I'm not gonna drink the whole
glass it smells like vomit
thank you so much welcome to BuzzFeed
taste test live
I'm your host Keith hammers burger
tonight's show is all about nachos
the thing about nachos is even a shitty
nacho is still a pretty good nacho it's
still a nacho it's sort of like sex in
that regard I'm not gonna spend a lot of
time comparing sex to nachos I think you
get that it's all messy and we get that
but I want to prove my theory that even
a cheap average nacho it's still pretty
ok so our first taste test is of the
cheapest most average nacho which is of
course from 7-eleven here to taste it
live right now our BuzzFeed's very own
Maisie Jenn and Jordan
they don't look bad no I can smell them
already yeah you just eat them that's
what you do with nothing it's a taste
test show Jen it's a little plastic eat
the cheeses it's a lot it's not bad it's
perfectly adequately Jen is the only one
who's into plastics she's fine with it
even the chips don't say it's good when
do you think you would actually eat
these in real life when I was drunk I
would eat them absolutely right when
you're drunk is the perfect time to have
7-eleven nachos and we thought about
ahead of time so why don't we bring out
three shots of tequila all right bottoms
up ladies
all right don't get too carried away the
thing is we're actually gonna take you
now to a room with more tequila and you
are free to drink as much of that as you
like obviously stay responsible with it
then we're gonna have you come back at
the end of this show and eat those same
nachos and see if maybe you find him a
little more delicious huh
[Applause]
how was the tequila room and I guess the
cervesa room as well over tequila's if
you were this drunk on a normal night
what time in the evening would it be six
9:30 oh I don't think this they like to
pee yeah that's the tequila talking
let's dig on home why don't you try a
retry those 7-eleven nachos now drunk
[Applause]
our new 7-eleven nachos sir I don't know
I've been here the whole time I think I
think they're actually new we tried to
provide you with the same of course it
is
Jordan you ate that so quickly put the
whole disc in your mouth I liked them
before but they're really good how do
they make you feel you're having a great
time up there Jordans just giggling are
you like turned on by these nachos
what's going on over there talk about
arena
use the guacamole on the table it up in
better at Gotham Olli but I'm not eating
you could be happy me what question are
these nachos better now that you're
drunk yeah like 100 percent we did it
guys I got you guys all drunk right in
front of all these people that's sort of
embarrassing I thought to make it fair I
would allow you guys to embarrass me so
we actually have all the ingredients to
make nachos we're gonna bring them out
here with a blender since I eat things
drunk you're gonna make me drink things
I should eat there's probably a logical
misstep in there but we all want to see
me jugs have not just you right
[Applause]
just a dash of milk that's important in
a recipe all right good know stay
focused on the job ladies we got it we
got to blend this stuff up all right
watch watch yourself I think it looks
like we made a pretty big liquid out of
those nachos I think we're ready to do
this I'm not gonna drink the whole glass
it smells like vomit I mean it's
literally chewed up nachos and booze it
is vomit here at BuzzFeed taste test
live having so much fun we tasted so
many things
we did it all guys and you all were here
to help it all happen thanks so much for
coming out to BuzzFeed taste test live I
think you can clearly say this is not
your ordinary show we did it
oh it's vile